lorry drivers on their way to other
European countries a woman makes a
charge free call abroad on her
smartphone these seemingly banal actions
are the result of one of the most
remarkable achievements in European
history the single market from the
Nordic lights in a Mediterranean Sun we
have freedom of movement for people
goods services money we are the biggest
integrated market in the world it brings
together 28 EU states and 4 non EU
states increasing economic competition
and abolishing hundreds of legal and
bureaucratic national barriers
laboring countries like Turkey or
Georgia are given selective access in
two and a half decades and more than a
dozen countries joined the single market
for obvious reasons the free movement of
goods that generates 25 percent of GDP
every year boosting employment and
investment there are no fees for
cross-border transactions and bank
transfers are now free of charge
ending obstacles to accessing digital
goods and services like unjustified geo
blocking could yield an extra four
hundred and fifteen billion euros a year
the free movement of data which is part
of all the other free movement is going
to really create enormous benefits to
our citizens and it is the digital
entrepreneurship that is going to give a
lot of solutions to people's problems if
we allow an enable and facilitate this
remove
you